i'm here with palmer luckey who's the
founder of oculus VR and you're making
something which i think is so cool this
is a headset for virtual reality games
exactly you put it on and you can hook
it into a compatible game and it's like
you're you feel like you're inside of
the game rather than looking at on the
screen and so when i turn my head the
world turns with me exactly it turns it
in response to whatever turn you've made
so if you turn exactly 90 degrees the
game world also counter rotates at 20
degrees it moves the camera around
inside the game like your head is moving
in real life so to you it seems like you
know you're looking around inside of a
virtual space is not show progress I've
tried one of these a long time ago and I
honestly I got a little mmm so there's a
wide variety of things that can cause
simulator sickness like latency
basically lag in the system or in crim
precise motion tracking or not
reflecting translation through the
environment and those are all things
we've been working on really heavily and
we have some internal prototypes that
nobody has any issues with but it's
always going to be content development
or content dependent there's a lot of
things that happen in video games today
that would not be possible for a person
to do in real life without getting sick
either so you got to balance that and
now this is originally when is your
product launch oh we don't have anything
officially announced yet okay but it's
not out yet you right right now we're
right so we raised 2.4 million dollars
on Kickstarter we did a series a for 16
million and we've sold about 45,000
developer kits only developer kids go to
people who are developing games or game
engines for this sort of thing both we
have partnerships with a lot of
different game engine developers and
also game developers so we ship them all
over the place originally or is this not
been decided yet this is going to be for
the PC or is it going to be for the new
xbox one for the ps4 or is it going to
be for all of them it's going to be for
pc and mobile it's not up to us if it
gets to be on the consoles to do that
they would have to approve it as a
peripheral and the game developers could
support it there's no technical reason
it wouldn't work but you know we don't
get to make that decision so for mobile
you mean I literally could plug this
into my iPhone and into a phone or a
tablet and then run that you know
without having to have any kind of
computer hooked up to it and in the long
run it's all going to be mobile hardware
running on the headset not for our first
consumer product probably not even a
second but some day in the future it's
going to all run on the head
so Palmer right before we start as enemy
you told me that you were studying of
all things journalism at Cal State and
you decided how did you get from
journalism to doing this I've always
been doing this kind of stuff so I
started the company in 2012 but I've
actually been working on it since I was
like 15 so I've been working with
virtual reality and all kinds of
different hardware and pc gaming in
general and I was doing journalism
because I was really interested in
journalism and wanted to be a tech
journalists that understood how the
technology worked rather than just
someone who parented what they thought
they understood about the technology and
then the opportunity that's what
journalists generally do we pair it what
we think we understand about things we
don't know I don't want to criticize
anyone but i was hoping to be oh that's
been my career pepper that's what I do
well you know some people do a good job
of that too but I thought there was a
place for someone who understood
engineering to pursue journalism and I
felt like I knew enough about
engineering to pursue journalism and
maybe not enough you know maybe knew
enough about engineering to not need to
pursue engineering and then an
opportunity came up and it looked like I
was going to be able to do this not just
as a hobby but as you know real thing
and so I dropped out of school that's
great so we only have a couple seconds
left here so in five years are you still
going to be doing this or there's gonna
be headsets in every pot where we're
going to be I don't know if they're
everyone will have a headset but it's
what i'm going to be doing i'm gonna be
doing it until it happens or I die last
question Palmer what's your favorite
video game Chrono Trigger my favorite
game